o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
se você saberia mencionar um sítio
arqueológico provavelmente passou pela
sua cabeça as pirâmides do Egito algum
prédio Romano talvez Pompéia quem sabe
extremamente ou aqui nas Américas a
Machu Picchu dos incas uma pirâmide
Asteca do México e se eu te disser que
aqui no Brasil tem mais de 27 mil sítios
arqueológicos já conhecidos e
registrados alguns dos mais destacados
são os seguintes os Magníficos geoglifos
do Acre chamados por alguns grupos
indígenas de tatuagens da Terra as
gravuras rupestres Do Costão do Santinho
em Florianópolis Santa Catarina
é o caso do Valongo no Rio de Janeiro
considerado patrimônio cultural da
humanidade pela Unesco desde 2017 o
registrar a dolorosa memória do terrível
comércio de pessoas que eram
escravizados e trazidos para as Américas
desde a África
E destaco também o complexo Arqueológico
do Parque Nacional da Serra da capivara
no Piauí também Patrimônio da Humanidade
pela Unesco ele engloba uma área de 100
mil hectares aonde tem mais de 700
sítios arqueológicos lá tudo é
superlativo eles têm a maior
concentração de pinturas rupestres do
mundo tem sítios arqueológicos quais
cerâmicas mais antigas das Américas com
cerca de nove mil anos de idade tem
também o sítio arqueológico Toca do
Boqueirão da Pedra Furada com Artefatos
em pedras lascadas que datam de até 100
mil anos atrás ó
em todos os sítios arqueológicos já
conhecidos no Brasil são registrados
pelo Instituto do patrimônio histórico e
artístico nacional O iphan que é um
órgão do governo federal e vocês podem
encontrar mais informações no site deles
mas o que é um sítio arqueológico para
que ele serve Por que devem ser
preservados e o que acontece se eles
forem destruídos
se você quer que eu Lógico é uma área
aonde estão depositados fisicamente os
materiais resultantes de alguma
atividade humana do passado
em vários desses vídeos já foram
estudados isso não significa que tenham
sido esgotados mas Outros tantos ainda
estão por ser estudados ou ainda nem
foram identificados
é uma coisa que é preciso saber é como
fazemos para saber a data de uma coisa
que eu lógica o método mais conhecido é
adaptação rádio carbônica o carbono-14
eu não vou aqui explicar o processo de
hidratação físico-química mas o que nos
interessa aqui é saber o que pode ser da
pato por motivos óbvios só podem ser
tratadas as coisas que tenham carbono
mas presta atenção se eu pegar um
diamante ou uma rocha de grafite que são
feitas de carbono e dá pra ver o
resultado foi esse é o momento de
Formação dessa rocha e não do seu uso ou
seja eu não posso pegar uma ponta de
flecha de pedra e dá pá porque isso vai
me dizer quando essa Rocha foi formada
na natureza e não quando ela foi lascada
por uma pessoa
bom então para saber a data de uma
atividade humana é preciso pegar o
carbono de alguma coisa que era viva no
momento da atividade como plantas
madeira ossos como os arqueólogos fazem
então no processo de escavar o sítio
arqueológico a gente vai fazendo de modo
a entender a relação entre as coisas que
estão ali e caso encontre algo que pode
ser adaptado Aí sim dá para sugerir aqui
a data obtida pode se referir a todo
aquele conjunto
o outro processo de hidratação também
físico-químico tem o nome de TL loi que
significa termoluminescência e
luminescência opticamente estimulada
essa técnica me diz a data da última vez
que um grão de cristal de alguns tipos
de minerais Foram estimulados pela
última vez ou seja quando um solo ou
sedimento foi soterrado e não foi mais
estimulado pelos raios ultravioletas do
sol ou quando os grãos que compõem uma
pecinha de cerâmica por exemplo foram
expostos ao fogo
e nos dois casos vocês têm bem podem
observar como o contexto das coisas aqui
o lógicas faz toda a diferença
Ah mas por que preservar esse sítios
arqueológicos esses terrenos esses
lugares arqueológicos
e vamos europeus chegaram aqui ali por
volta de 1.500 muita coisa já tinha
acontecido nesse continente estima-se
que naquela época tinha cerca de mil
línguas indígenas diferentes entre os
povos indígenas que viviam por aqui
atualmente tem cerca de 270 línguas
indígenas conhecidas em atividade a
título de comparação em toda a Europa
hoje são 60 línguas menos de um quarto
do que temos de línguas indígenas no
Brasil hoje mesmo depois de cinco
séculos de genocídios e
e como isso aconteceu como tantos idioma
se estabeleceram aqui e a resposta é com
o tempo muito tempo e sofisticação
e a gente chama de história indígena
profunda
Nem pense em tudo que mudou de 1.500 até
agora em 500 anos as alterações na
paisagem que a gente consegue
identificar prédios cidades Rio
certificados morto morros derrubados
plantações fazendas os indígenas também
alteraram ambiente plantaram florestas
abriram clareiras levavam plantas de um
lado para o outro domesticavam plantas e
animais faziam edificações estradas
conectando aldeias eguaras distantes
muitos quilômetros
e agora calcule o tanto de coisa que se
passou nesse continente antes de 1500
a outra pergunta você sabe de onde como
e quando os povos originarios os
indígenas vieram para as Américas se
você for um excelente aluno na escola
você deve responder claro que sei pelos
preto de Behringer lá no Alasca a 12 mil
anos bom esse é o modelo mais bem aceito
até o momento mas ainda faltam algumas
pecinhas no grande quebra-cabeças que é
a dispersão do stakes pelo mundo a parte
da África recentemente niéde guidon uma
arqueóloga brasileira que trabalha na
Serra da capivara no Piauí afirmou que
os registros encontrados lá sugerem uma
migração diretamente a partir do
continente africano em datas que
remontam a 100 mil anos
e agora em 2021 foi publicado por um
outro pesquisador mais um artigo com
evidência de uma rota de imigração
trans-pacífica e existem até outros
propósitos como rotas transatlânticas
tanto da América da Europa para a
América do Norte como da África para a
América do Sul
o que eu quero dizer é que a história da
dispersão dos saquinhos pelo mundo é um
quebra-cabeça e científico gigante que
ainda não está completamente montado e
que a gente não tem certeza nem de
quantas peças têm e nem da figura que
forma no final
e entre os sítios arqueológicos
conhecidos no Brasil a gente tem vários
tipos de aldeias indígenas algumas
parecidas com as atuais outras
diferentes Nesse sítio se encontram
muitos fragmentos de peças cerâmicas
também tem sítios Nos quais predominam
peças líticas dia dizer em Rocha tem
sítios que foram casas subterrâneas
sítios de arte rupestre e principalmente
no litoral sul tem os Sambaquis que são
ovos de diferentes alturas que foram
construídos com Conchas e um monte de
outras coisas
e os Sambaquis são o registro material
bastante bem preservado de um povo que
ocupou boa parte do litoral Atlântico
eles compunham aldeias caçavam pescavam
e coletavam tinha uma população que
variava entre algumas centenas alguns
milhares de pessoas eles viviam em
transitavam por todo o litoral nesse
Sambaquis tem vestígios de ferramentas
de trabalho de coisas relacionadas à
alimentação de sepultamento de entes
queridos tem muitos esqueletos
sepultados com rituais e adaptação
desses povos que são acestrais dos
indígenas varia entre 8 mil até os 1.500
Anos Antes do presente ou seja os 6 a 7
mil anos Desse pessoal fazendo coisas
por aí se relacionando se
e quando comendo dormindo plantando
colhendo pescando se divertindo brigando
contando história passando conhecimento
de geração para outra de como fazer isso
tudo e essa história desse pessoal do
litoral é uma história que se conecta
com os outros povos indígenas que
habitavam o continente no mesmo período
e com a dispersão dos Sapiens pelo mundo
mas ainda tem muitas pecinhas para se
encaixarem por aí por isso é importante
encontrar os sítios arqueológicos e
preservados para que possam aos poucos
serem estudados fica a dica não destruam
as peças do quebra-cabeça do estáveis